سمعت الطيران السيئه لا تنبثق من عدم فسجل
هذه الدوله الواقعه بجبال هيمالايا حافل
بالكوارث الجويه نبات معروفا ان ظروف
الطيران الصعبه بالبلاد تقف خلف هذه
الحوادث مثل طقس العاصف وانخفاض الرؤيا
والتضاريس الجبليه فنبال التي يبلغ عدد
سكانها 99 مليون نسمه تحوي ثمانيه من اعلى
14 جبلا في العالم الطائرات الصغيره
مشاهدينا كذلك التي تستخدم للوصول الى
الاجزاء النائيه والجبليه في البلاد تساهم
بسمعه الطيران السيئه هذه الطائرات تحتوي
على 19 مقعدا او اقل وتكثر فرص تحطمها من
خلال الاحوال الجويه السيئه بحسب تقرير
هيئه الطيران المدنيه التعليم كما اكد
طبعا مشغله الطائرات ان بلادهم تفتقر الى
المنشات التي تتيح توقع الاحوال الجويه
الدقيقه خصوصا في المناطق الجبليه النائيه
فالطقس سريع التغير في الجبال في هذه
المناطق مطارات النيبال مشاهدينا الجزء
الاكبر من المشكله مطار لوكلا مفعلان
الواقع شمال شرقي البلاد يعد اخطر مطار في
العالم مع تمركز مدرج المطار على منحدر
بين الجبال كما نشاهد هنا يذكر ان القطاع
الطيران في النيبال شهد ازدهارا بسبب
السياحه غير انه واجه مشكله في ضمان سلامه
الرحلات بسبب عدم كفاءه الطيارين والنقص
في الصيام
[موسيقى]